By the way we got to get to a what the Florida segment we should do guys shapes
puppy from monster alligator, while smoking a cigar.
We got to just end it on this story because I'm in,
this is some Florida right here. I'm sure you guys have seen this, but I mean,
let's break this down. Here you go. This has to be Florida. If it's not Florida,
then it's still Florida.
Charles spaniel and rested from the jaws of the alligator. It tastes,
Oh my God. The puppy did so for a puncture to it's Billy,
but it's doing just fine. Oh my God, dude.
The one thing they cut off, how do you get your fingers out at the end?
Yeah. What did he do? I mean, I don't, he couldn't,
he might just be so old school that he got a finger bitten off.
It didn't even mention it.
Right. Is that, is that hardcore? Because if you've ever been bit by a puppy.
It, well, yeah, it doesn't hurt. Right?
Does it? No, it does.
They have the sharpest little teeth similar to like a tiny alligator,
a baby alligator like that dude, they could lock your finger off clean.
Do you think there's any chance in hell that that guy voted for Joe Biden?
If you imagine.
Yeah. They interview him after and he's like, Oh,
I just saw my little puppy in there and I just had to save them.
Yeah. It's like, I'm just hoping. He's like,
what are you hoping for it for Chris? He's like,
I'm just hoping for a smooth transition to the president.
Um, all right, bubbas, here we go. Uh, this is our,
that was our pseudo penis moment, our PPM cause he was, he was a bear. I mean,
you did great filling in for Jani. Jani has COVID he's going to be fine.
We'll be back next week. Where can people find you, Mike? You see.
Uh, at IMI cannon, social media, Mike Cannon, comedy, YouTube, and we all,
I also have a Patrion with Mike Feeney. Uh, the,
the emaciated man of comedy and Brendan Sagel Tagalog called, uh,
what's the scenario it's patrion.com/scenario pod.
[Inaudible].